Jennifer we have a very special guest on
one of our favorite people
here in st. Louis is with the Maurice
that's right we have a chief curator
over at the world chess Hall of Fame
Shannon Bailey is with Maurice to talk
about all the excitement going on across
the street and I think Shannon was
looking at that and saying that puzzles
too easy come on well yes Shannon one of
our favorite people and doing great work
at the world chess Hall of Fame such
amazing displays going on every single
time how does it feel it with your staff
you guys are you overworked overwhelmed
or is it just fun all this are overjoyed
good answer
almost all of us have been there since
the very beginning so it's like a family
it's great we all gel real well together
we know how to work off of each other
really well so it's been wonderful it's
great to go over there we always have
this opening and closing ceremonies in
just such a classic location great place
to work tell us about what's going on
now with the world chess Hall of Fame
starting with painted pieces which is
it's a beautiful yeah so we are working
with pearl in London and they're
fantastic we've always wanted to work
with them we had a couple of sets of
theirs from Sophie Matisse and a and
yellow HEV that were in our ladies night
show a couple years ago and we always
thought we needed to do a whole show
with them so just pieces yeah we've got
20 international artists who contributed
to the show some brand new just for
state Louis's show we've been bringing
in some of the artists so actually this
week Nettie Robinson will be here for an
event
on Thursday night at the Hall of Fame if
you're around please come down and they
they kind of encompass everything they
took the stunts and set and each artist
manipulated it into some kind of special
meaning or kind of like a copy of their
own work so this is the Staunton this is
a different really I know that that I
had Frank Cammarata and John Crowe
Miller it did occur they did they were
in a panel yeah Saturday we brought them
in so they are two of the key
contributors to our stunts in standard
exhibition and that is on our second
floor and that is looking at what came
before stock and why Stanton is
important then and why it's still used
now still use a classic design yes and
the play is playing with that classy
design as well talk about another one
you have the sink field effect which
certainly goes into what Rex and Jeanne
have contributed to changing American
chess and even world chess that was an
emotional exhibition to put together
because I was at the ribbon-cutting of
the chess club I was lucky enough to be
involved before I was even at the Hall
of Fame and we know that everyone is
doing great things here in st. Louis for
chest and and for the world but to
actually have looked at it all at one
time to see the impact that Rex and
Jeanne have had on chess in America it
was it was really a moving project work
on yes and I know as we look here we've
seen some great pieces intersection of
art and chest part of the thing is that
Rex and Jeanne also loved the idea of
art and music yeah and they'd like to
act to blend that together and that's
really a beautiful beautiful partnership
now the Hall of Fame isn't just about
chess history it's about the
intersection of chess and culture and
chess in life and so we have great
programming music series we've got one
tomorrow night they are standing room
only we saw them out weeks in advance
other things that Rex mangini like we
work a lot with the chess and Boy Scouts
so that's part of the exhibit with the
same field effect you have composer
series we have great programming for
kids and then adults if you want to come
we've got book clubs or these like
crafts and cocktails where there's a
signature cocktail and there's a craft
of rotating about an exhibition I met
people who are non chess players or so
yeah I've been to that place even though
they don't play chess because of all
those great activities speaking of this
amazing place larger than life
you do have the Lotte world's largest
chest piece there as well again that's
right because you had it before but
someplace we won't even mention them
broke the record so you had to go bigger
yes so we had the first record in 2012
it was taken from us not long after that
and then this past August I'm sorry
April April 12th we unveiled a 20-foot
sing filled cup King and it is it weighs
over 10,000 pounds it's over nine feet
at the base and it is beautiful it is
anybody wants to go bigger you know Rex
doesn't like to lose trying again and
finally tell us what's up next you must
have you always have things in the works
what if you are traveling in and out of
st. Louis right now you can see we have
an exhibition at the airport it's all
about trust and pop culture we actually
have people come to the Hall of Fame
that didn't know we existed because they
saw the exhibit at the airport that's
some good marketing for us we've got the
grand chest tour our chests over at the
Hall of Fame on the third floor as well
and then we have Peter Mannion a local
artist who's opening up in October and
we are so honored to have Harry Benson
back in st. Louis we're doing an
operation dog refer a great photographer
he's doing we're doing a show of his
called kings and queens so it's Bobby
Fischer in the 70s actual kings and
queens and world leaders and then he is
coming this weekend to shoot more
photography of our players in the
Ziegfeld cup and some of those photos
will be in the show I know he did a
great photo of Magnus Carlsen and
Fabiano Caruana 2014 right and they were
arm wrestling or something like yeah
activities little precedent of what was
to come
yeah the great match well thank you so
much thanks Shannon
barely the chief curator of the world
chess Hall of Fame an amazing place when
you come to st. Louis to visit chess
club you will be visiting the world's
just Hall of Fame as well